ANDREW BROGDON: Hey, everybody.
I'm Andrew Brogdon and welcome
back to the Mobile Ads Garage.
Today, with the help of
Gary the graphics guy,
I'm going to cover
the ad lifecycle.
I'm going to show
you what events occur
in the life of an ad, how to use
listeners and delegates to tap
into them, and then I'll
have a real world example
that puts it all together.
If you're not already
familiar with ad events,
they are a fundamental
piece of the mobile ads SDK.
They can tell you what's
going on with your ads,
like when they're done loading,
when they've opened, and so on.
Every format has them, so if
you're using the SDK at all,
this is an important
thing to know about.
So here are the basic events
in the life of an AdMob ad.
Now, some formats
have some extra stuff.
Reward a Video has a
reward event, for example.
But these are the big five.
Let's drill down.
When you make an
ad request, the ad
either loads or fails to load.
So those are the
first two events.
If the ad does load
successfully, you move on.
First up is presenting, also
called opening, on Android.
This means that the ad
has caused something
to appear on screen that
covers your interface.
When an interstitial or rewarded
video ad gets displayed,
for example, this event happens.
It's a way for the
SDK to say, heads up,
I just covered your
UI with something.
The opposite of
opening, of course,
is closing, or
dismissing, the ad.
And last, we have
leaving the app.
When the user taps
on an ad, and the SDK
opens a browser or
another app in response,
you get this event.
And it's actually the
best one, because it
means the user and the ad were
a good match for each other,
and you get credit
for a clickthrough.
All right.
So those are the
big five events,
but how do you tap into them?
For that, the SDK offers
listeners on Android
and delegates on iOS.
There's actually a
few different kinds.
There you go.
It's a scary big list,
but the good news
is, you don't have
to memorize it.
The ad object will tell you.
If you're on iOS, just look
for a delegate property.
And on Android, look for
a set listener method.
You find that, and
you know which type
of listener or delegate
goes with the object.
For example, here's the set
listener method for an ad view.
I can see from the signature
that it takes an AdListener
object.
And for iOS, it's the same deal.
Just look for a delegate
property on the ad object.
There you go,
GADBannerViewDelegate.
Once you've got that, make
your own implementation
and add methods for the
events you're interested in.
Loading, for
example, on Android,
you can override the
onAdLoaded method, and, on iOS,
you implement DidReceiveAd.
When an ad fails
to load, there's
onAdFailedToLoad, and
DidFailToReceiveAdWithError.
These include an error code
that describes the problem.
For an ad opening,
there's onAdOpened and
willPresentScreen.
And for dismissing
or closing, you
have onAdClosed on
Android, and two methods
on iOS, willDismissScreen,
and didDismissScreen.
So you can get notified
before and after the event.
And finally, if a
clickthrough opens
a browser or external app, there
is willLeaveApplication on iOS,
and onAdLeft
application on Android.
One last little detail,
and it's actually
a difference between the
platforms-- on Android,
leaving the app also
counts as opening the ad
if it's not already open.
So if your user taps on
a banner, for example,
you'll get onAdOpened,
then onAdLeftApplication,
and, when the user comes back,
you'll see onAdClose get fired.
So that's a little extra info
you get from the Android SDK.
All right, so we've
covered the events
and how to find
the right listener
or delegate and use it.
Let's put it all
together with an example.
Say you've got an Android
app that plays music videos
and have monetized it
with a Native Express ad.
There's the interface.
There's a bunch of ways that
ad events can help me here.
But first, I need
to get wired up.
Here are the steps.
First, I'm going to set an ad
listener for my Native Express
ad.
Now I'm going to add individual
methods for the events I
care about, and then rock out.
So step one, setting
the listener.
Native Express Ad view objects
accept the ad listener class.
So I can call set ad listener
and my activities onCreate,
and give it an instance, just
like I would with an onClick
listener for a button.
And that's it, listener set.
Now I can add individual methods
for the events I care about.
Let's say my ad view
starts out hidden,
and I want to show it
once the ad is loaded.
All I need to do is
override onAdLoaded and put
in the code to make it visible.
So I get something like this.
How about when the
ad fails to load?
Maybe I'd like to try
again, just in case.
All I have to do is
add another method
to my listener for
onAdFailedToLoad.
It's good to put some
kind of flag or count
in place, though, to
make sure you don't keep
trying to load an ad over
and over again, if there's
no internet connection.
Otherwise, the SDK
will keep dutifully
trying to load forever.
Now this app is all
about playing music
videos, which is great, because
Gary rocks like no other.
Ironically, that's
actually true.
But if my user taps on
an ad and leaves the app
to go to a browser, I probably
want to stop video playback.
I can do that by adding a
listener method override
for on ad left application,
and then some code
to stop playback.
That way, when a user taps
on an ad, the video gets
paused, just as they leave for
a browser or the Play Store.
And onAdClose tells me
the user has come back
from leaving the
app, so it's time
to crank the party back up.
All right, so that's
our real-world example.
I've got a Native
Express ad that's
shown when it's done
loading, and an app
that smart enough
to pause playback
when there's a click through.
This is the power that
ad events give you,
and they're a great tool
to have in your belt.
I used Android for
this video, but if you
code in Swift or Objective C,
we've got an example for you
up on GitHub.
I'll also sneak in
our Android example
for anybody who's interested.
I've got guides that I can
point you to for both platforms.
And as always, you're welcome to
bring your technical questions
to our support forum.
And if you've got a
question about this video,
or an idea for something
we should cover,
leave a comment below, and Gary
and I will see you next time.